êtes journaliste et militant antiraciste
franco-algérien vous avait 22 ans vous
définissez comme journaliste des luttes
vous avez donc été interpellé et placé
en garde à vue vendredi dernier pour
avoir tweeté sur la présence d' emmanuel
macron au théâtre des bouffes du nord
vous avez filmé une vidéo dans laquelle
on verrait emmanuel et brigitte m'a
concourir en entendant les manifestants
ont essayé d'entrer dans le théâtre
votre téléphone a été confisquée par la
police où il avait été libéré et placé
sous le statut de témoin assisté alors
que le parquet demandait une mise en
examen
vous avez été le plus jeune candidat aux
élections législatives de 2010 est à 19
ans sur une liste de la france insoumise
dans l'isère et c'est vous qui avez
filmé alexandre benalla avec les
manifestants le 1er mai 2018 voilà c'est
vous qui avez fini alors déjà comment
avez vous été prévenus de la présence du
président de la république au théâtre
des bouffes du nord est et je finissais
ma journée de boulot comme d'habitude on
veut rentrer chez moi je me rendais
précisément à une soirée à une soirée de
lancement d'une bd sur alexandre benalla
une bd
d'ariane chemin quand je reçois une
information d'une source qui m'explique
que le président de la république sera
présent dans un théâtre dans le théâtre
des bouffes du nord ce soir donc j'y
suis pas allé par hasard qu'on explique
ici que je me suis retrouvé par hasard
par la non j'y suis allé parce que
j'avais une information je me suis dit
ça valait peut-être le coup d'y aller
voir ce qui s'y passait donc j'ai eu
plus tard l'information que des
militants alertés trop du tout seul
j'étais tout seul effectivement j'étais
seul je suis allé prendre la place seul
j'ai assisté à quasiment toute la
représentation seul d'accord javier fait
en sorte d'être proche de lui ou c'est
le hasard
en fait quand je prends ma place déjà
j'ai envie de pouvoir voir la pièce
comme il faut donc je prends plus la
mouche française bon moi j'ai pas grand
amateur de théâtre
d'accord mais bon vous avez quand même
trouvé des places au dernier au bon
plein fouet au dernier moment
oui parce qu'au dernier moment j'ai pas
été spécialement enfin bon cheval et
j'ai pris une place j'ai pris une place
au devant
je me suis dit aussi que le présent
république n est pas forcément être
derrière dans le théâtre
il se trouve que je me retrouve trois
rangées derrière lui d'accord donc là
vous êtes trois rangs derrière emmanuel
macron vous avez publié une vidéo
on va voir
voilà c'est vous montrer qu emmanuel
macron il vous twittez je suis
actuellement au théâtre des bouffes du
nord
métro la chapelle ce qui vous a été
reprochée reproché de mettre le métro à
la station de métro
trois rangées derrière le président de
la république des militants sont quelque
part dans le coin et appelle tout le
monde à rappliquer quelque chose se
prépare
la soirée risque d'être mouvementée
pourquoi avoir fait ce tweet classement
voilà
écoutez moi mon travail c'est de rendre
compte des informations et là j'ai rendu
compte d'une information c'est la
présence du président de la république
dans ce théâtre et le fait que des
militants appelés à se rassembler devant
ce théâtre donc
donc vous avez eu l'info comme quoi des
militants ça a appelé à se rassembler
l'information sur les réseaux sociaux et
17 10 il va se passer quelque chose
savaient choo exactement y avait un
appel à se rassembler donc c'était pas
un appel vous justement à venir et à
venir manifester ou à venir voilà
s'attaquer aux proches croient que le
tout il est assez clair c'est des
militants sont quelque part dans le coin
et appelle à rappliquer quelque chose se
prépare à la soirée de mouvementée jeudi
pas venez les gars [ __ ] le bordel
lannoy a été pris comme ça écoutez ça
peut être certes comme ça peut être pris
comme comme comme chacun le souhaite en
tout cas la juge a estimé
parce que je suis était déféré devant un
magistrat là on parlait la garde à vue
oui elle a estimé qu'il y avait pas le
moindre élément pour établir la
matérialité des faits qui lui étaient
reprochés
alors qu'est ce qui se passe est
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quand les
manifestants essayez de d'entrée vu de
l'intérieur de la salle parce que le
président est donc à trois routes vous
qu'est ce qui se passe en fait nous on
n'a pas de vision sur ce qui se passe
puisque on à la pièce en face de nous et
on répond à la porte
les bouffes du nord s'est enfin ccba et
en fait on à la porte principale que
vous voyez ici dans votre main l'écran
alors d'accord
voilà voilà il ya une seconde porte
juste derrière une porte rouge là
d'accord en fait on a 15 mètres entre la
porte principale et la porte qui donne
sur la sur la pièce de théâtre d'accord
et donc on entend une porte s'ouvrir
battre et on entend rapidement emmanuel
macron 20 des slogans anti macron
d'accord et des gens qui sont entrés
dans la salle de la pièce de théâtre et
donc on voit le président de la
république ainsi que la première dame se
lever et hors catastrophes partir avec
donc le gspr le groupe de sécurité du
président de la république est en fait
le truc c'est qu'il sait qu'il ya une
sortie en fait qui à droite et sortent
pas le même endroit où les manifestants
sont rentrés pendant que des policiers
est en train de repousser à l'extérieur
pour moi qu'est ce que je fais je file
un jeu filmé cette scène et je descends
je suis en fait le mouvement est en fait
en arrivant le président on a déjà deux
salles une salle à gauche une salle à
droite qui prend soin la salle à gauche
dans la salle à droite et des
manifestants sont en train d'être
repoussée à la porte de delà du théâtre
d'accord par les forces de l'ordre
alors donc la sécurité présidentielle a
rapidement été tenue donc au courant ils
ont fait sortir le président togo nous
l'avait dit puis le président aurait été
escortée regarder
[Musique]
alors vous avez pu filmer ce qui s'est
passé oui j'aime le film est donc dès
que j'ai entendu
sachant qu'il allait se passer quelque
chose dès que j'ai entendu du bruit
enfin j'ai vu les j'ai entendu les
manifestants entrée dans la pièce j'ai
directement pris mon téléphone
vous savez moi je filme avec mon
téléphone je couvre les mouvements
sociaux je voulais conflits sociaux et
donc j'ai rapide j'ai l'habitude de
rapidement dégainé mon téléphone
bon je trouve que la javel informations
donc rapidement je dégaine mon téléphone
immédiatement et on a cette scène qui à
ces jeux les jeux les déjà dit dans le
passage à quotidien mais qui est assez
terrible finalement pour l'image du
président de la république c'est un
président qui fuient devant une
trentaine de manifestants qui étaient
venus lui demander des comptes
moi je dis pas que j'ai pour que je peux
comprendre qu'il ait pris peur et bien
sûr voudrais pas tout moi même j'ai moi
moi moi ni moi même personnellement vous
avez eu peur vous aussi moi j'ai eu peur
qu'ils génèrent moi j'ai été
impressionnée moi j'ai eu peur quand
j'ai été placé en garde à vue et que
l'on m'a dit viens on m'a dit que
j'allais être déféré devant un magistrat
alors on va en parler dans un instant
parce que vous auriez vu cette scène
mais je filme cette sem est à cette
image terrible où en fait on a un
président qui fuit en fait finalement
s'est manifestée alors j'ai une image
terrible mais c'est vrai que son image
ces images terribles mais alors oui mais
c'est vrai qu'il serait que c'était
compliqué de faire à ce moment là donc
quand je filme cette scène je me fais
arracher le téléphone mais par un manque
du j'espère du coup je roule de sécurité
du président de la république thomas
ouais voilà alors il ya un vrai effet
mis le couple présidentiel fuir en
courant mais certains vous accuse de
mentir
alors il ya une employée du théâtre qui
confirme cette version et il ya roselyne
bachelot qui était présente aux bouffes
du nord vendredi soir qui livre un récit
différent
regardez l'emploi et théâtre sont partis
en courant et au bout de peut-être dix
minutes
emmanuel macron est revenu
dans les bouffes du nord mais seul et
après il est resté jusqu'à la fin du
spectacle et il a applaudi après il ya
eu des petites perturbations devant le
théâtre donc ils ont fermé l'entrée
principale ils nous ont fait passer par
le all star biétry alors et roselyne
bachelot qui était présente au bout du
nord livre un récit différent regarder
effectivement j'étais bien dans la salle
de représentation avec emmanuel macron p
il a été très calme le président
effectivement il délaisse que bourrin
dans les représentations on a compris
qui se passe chacun
oui on a compris qu'il se passait
quelque chose quand on entendu on est là
on est là macron démission là on en
rêvait on aurait été vraiment content de
pas comprendre c'est à dire que le
président a fait explique dre sa femme
d'ailleurs je comprends qu'ils
essayaient de la protéger qui met lui
les revenus est il à rester jusqu'à la
fin en applaudissant bizarre alors il ya
que roselyne bachelot cassette cake à
quai à cette version
mais la vraie version je vous le dis
c'est apparemment lol donc la version 2
de l'employé de théâtre un voile a
continué mme bachelot a amoindri c'était
une blague qu'elle a fait dans les
grosses têtes s'est dit choqué au state
je vais faire des blagues
moi je vois pas quel intérêt une
employée de théâtre à montvillers
là-dessus voisine bachelot peut-être
qu'elle veut un poste de ministre
chez makro voilà en tout cas c'est assez
c'est assez ridicule j'aurais pas monté
sur sa route et les fans devait le
récupérer
et puis et puis la vidéo je les
publierai on a dû faudra aller aux
grosses dates en sortant du théâtre vous
vous attendiez être interpellé écoutez
moi je je je ne sais pas si je
m'attendais pas à être interpellé dans
le sens où c'est jamais normal qu'un
journaliste soit interpellé quelle que
soit par ailleurs ses idées ce qui le
défend le média pour lequel il travaille
c'est pas quelque chose d'acceptable en
plus je m'attendais pas être interpellé
je m'attendais à assortir puisque sinon
je vous ai reproché quoi ta qu'est ce
qu'on m'a reproché en fait c'est la
chose qui vous la garde à vue
ces groupements en vue de commettre des
délits ou des violences
d'accord c'est quelque chose qui a été
mis en place aux sarkozy pour les bandes
à la base ça a bon dos je vous avais
aussi organisation d'une manifestation
dont gérard heitz a été ajouté après bac
en fait on m'arrête on ouvre la garde à
vue sur ça en fait je vois très mal
comment est-ce que j'aurais pu être dans
un groupement vue de commettre des
violences ou des délits quand j'étais
seul dans un théâtre avec ma place mais
pour eux il considérait que vous avez
appelé
un groupe à se former en vue de
commettre des violences ou des
dégradations avec votre tweet non mais
groupement ça veut dire groupement ça
veut pas dire tu es tout seul dans ton
bon et ensuite on ajoute appelle un
organisation organisation d'une
manifestation non déclarée
la juge a dit qu'il avait pas le moindre
début d'élément qui pouvait permettre
voilà d'établir ces faits là est la
raison pour laquelle moi je vais vous
dire cyril de la raison pour laquelle
pour moi j'ai été interpellé c'est d'une
part pour récupérer ce téléphone parce
qu'il ya une instruction qui a été
ouverte
il a été mis sous scellés pour éviter de
la diffusion de cette image et parce
qu'il ya un passif c'est vrai que je
suis aussi celui qui filme un
collaborateur du président de la
république place de la contrescarpe le
1er mai parler d'élection de bd et il ya
quelque part là une volonté de punir un
crime de lèse majesté aimeraient que
vous avez un contentieux électoraux
s'écouter moi ce personnage il
m'intéresse très peu je vous le dis
l'allier en plus à une soirée pour une
bd sur alexandre reynal ah ouais mais
moi ce personnage qui m'intéresserait
pas en tant que tel parce que ça devient
juste un troll sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est quelqu'un qui devrait plutôt
s'occuper de ses affaires de justice
avant de venir donner des leçons aux
gens sur twitter aussi bfmtv l'invité en
tant qu'expert sécurité
écoutez c'est bien pour lui mais moi je
dis ce soir là de marteler sur les
réseaux sociaux occupent tout est
affaire de justice mongrain alors
comment s'est déroulée votre
interpellation pourquoi vous arrêter
vous alors que le premier message
indiquant la présence du président de la
république il vient pas de vous en fait
je vous le dis moi j'ai plutôt
l'impression qu'on veut me punir d'avoir
entre guillemets gâché la soirée du
président de la république
cc cc je l' ai dit tout à l'heure cette
vidéo qui est terrible pour l'image du
président de la république
elle est en quelque sorte voix la mise
mise en
mise là mais sous scellés on veut pas
qu'elle soit diffusée et je pense que
c'est pour cette raison-là que caen
mâcon va passer en garde à vue alors
vous avez publié donc donc ce tweet
macron vient d'entrer au théâtre des
bouffes du nord pour assister à un
spectacle qui se moque de nous soyons
pitt et tous devant dès maintenant pour
l'accueillir comme il se doit
vous avez tous les cas avant mais ça
c'est pas moi qui ai fait ça alors non
c'est un autre conte qui avaient tous
été ça exactement mais vous vous avez
publié ce ce message sur twitter non
j'espère que lui et moi non non vous
avez publié votre message pourra dire là
je lui fais une george bush avec ma air
force one en référence dessus un sondage
sur sur george bush d'un journaliste
irakien à l'époque
donc voilà donc vous avez mis ça et ça a
été mal pris aussi ouais bah je peux
comprendre après moi je vous dis j'ai 22
ans
mais il se trouve que twitter c'est un
lieu d'information mais c'est aussi un
lieu pas d'humour de vannes de vannes
écoutez moi je crois que si j'avais
envie de jeter ma force one sur le
président j'aurais pas tweeté en mon nom
propre
ce serait pas ce serait un peu con je
peux comprendre que ce tweet après tout
la polémique on puisse dire bah ouais
c'est ça n'a pas lieu d'être
moi je sais pas si tout ce qui va se
passer après non pour moi je rentre chez
moi c'est fini
bon je peux comprendre que ça en gêne
certains moi ce que je suis comme ça je
provocateur ch un peu un peu malicieux
voilà alors j'avais bénéficié de
beaucoup de soutien notamment beaucoup
de la france insoumise
vous avez d'ailleurs été comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure candidat pour ce
parti au d'initiative de 2017 en isère
est-ce qu'on peut être journaliste et et
militants écoutez moi je me revendique
comme journaliste engagé c'est à dire
que je ne mens pas sur la vision que je
défends du monde sur la position que je
défends sur sur le projet de société qui
kim homme parle je crois que chaque
journaliste quand il écrit quelque chose
il ya un biais de parce qu'il a vécu de
par son origine sociale de pas et c'est
pas vrai que quand on écrit par exemple
un papier où quand on fait un sujet on
enlève son âme le temps du papier et
qu'on est totalement neutre
c'est pas vrai moi par contre n'y a pas
tromperie sur la marchandise moi mon
média c'est là-bas si j'y suis
l'émission de daniel mermet et quand
vous allez sur notre site le slogan
c'est plus près des jetables que des
notables
moi c'est pour les gens d'en bas et
j'écris sur les gens n'ont pas pour eux
voilà et moi on découvrira pas un beau
matin que je mange des au marché de rugy
on sait ce que je pense
voilà
sauras tu mangeais pas doma quand vous
êtes vous êtes arrêté vous êtes passés
en garde à vue tout de suite qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qu'on
vous dit en fait eu au début j'en
retranché en train de filmer
il ya d'abord juste un policier en fait
en fait qui m'a juste j'ai un truc que
j'ai promis de dire parce que on le dit
souvent quand ça se passe mal et ben en
fait quand ça se passe bien il faut le
dire aussi
j'ai été correctement traitées lors de
ma garde à vue de le dire d'un par les
policiers du 5 du commissariat du 5ème
arrondissement qui ont été corrects voir
simple je veux dire avec moi donc on le
dit quand ça se passe mal il ferait bien
de le dire quand ça se passe bien
bien sûr donc j'ai promis de le redire
donc là bravo route c'est bien d'eux est
donc en fait je donne mon identifiant me
demandent de décliner une pièce que vous
êtes du théâtre jeudi battue du stade
j'ai mon billet et c est en fait d'un
sas et avec un policier il demande juste
de sortir en fait à ce moment là il ya
un mec du j'espère qu'ils arrivent en
courant et qui dit qui marche mon
téléphone et qui disent cela ils bougent
pas d'accord et donc en fait c'est le
groupe de sécurité du président
république qui demandent mon
interpellation en fait donc c'est pas
les policiers eux mêmes qui prennent de
leur propre initiative
le fait de m'arrêter donc ensuite je
suis menotté on place dans une salle à
côté on vide le théâtre et quand il n'y
a plus personne dans le théâtre ont fait
monter dans un fourgon cellulaire
direction 5e arrondissement dans une
cellule au fourgon vous dit quoi on
parle ou pas en fait j'ai un jeune
policier qui me parlent pas avant que en
avant avant dans les fourgons
cellulaires mbia est à déconner là moi
j'en ai vu j'étais mort j'ai fait un
tweet est tout même duo ms comme c'est
comme dans x factor ta peine des potes
après tu sais pas ce qui se passe à ce
beau j'ai un jour j'ai un peu j'ai des
politiques sont assez cool avec moi je
monte dans le fourgon il me dit ah ben
là c'est chaud quand même bon on verra
ce qui va se passer mais on va ce qu'on
verra ce que dit le pgi loupé j'y prends
mon témoignage ma chance va lui tout se
passe cordialement et on va et il vous
dit quoi et vous dit pourquoi vous avez
fait ça ouais moi j'ai des policiers qui
viennent me voir pendant la garderie
mais qu'est ce qui se passe et où c'est
toi qui as fait le truc de match on a
tous moi je le raconte moi et mais ça se
passe plutôt vous dise quoi peuvent ils
vous lâche ou tous même temps
en fait je fais 22 heures de garde à vue
et deux heures dans ce qu'on appelle le
dépôt -c'est-à-dire seller stridulent du
tribunal de grande instance
donc en fait moi je suis là j'arrive
dans les cellules du tribunal de grande
instance et un vent mauvais plein de
gens qui sont là qui dorment en fait en
fait ils dorment au dépôt et sont jugées
devant deux mois ils ont fait ramener
magistrate le soir même pour moi ah
d'accord
et j'arrive les policiers
mais vous êtes un vip vous fait passer
on vous fait ramener une magistrate est
pour vous je suis donc la magistrate et
vous direz vous dit quoi écoutez moi
j'arrive devant la magistrate elle me
demande ma version
elle regarde le dossier el dib un bon
peux pas vous le parquet en fait c'est à
dire le procureur de la république qui
je le rappelle ici est lié au pouvoir
politique puisque c'est l'exécutif sait
c'est l'exécutif qui choisit les
procureurs qui sont sous l'autorité de
bélouve et donc la ministre de la
justice
donc pour moi c'est clairement une
instrumentalisation de la justice quand
le parquet demande la mise en examen
alors qu' aucun élément et la juge ne
suis pas le parquet et ne me mets pas en
examen je suis placé sous le témoin de
statut a cité parce qu'il ya toujours
une information judiciaire qui est en
cours
quand l'enquêté sera terminée et bien
libre de alors vous aviez twitté en
indiquant que vous ne parleriez pas du
tout chaîne info pourquoi écoutez moi je
suis assise assez sidéré du traitement
qui a été fait de cette affaire d'accord
rien puisque quand on a un jeune
confrère de 22 ans qui se retrouve dans
une cellule en garde à vue qui se fait
déférés devant un magistrat pour avoir
simplement m'a rendu compte d'une
situation donc avoir fait son boulot
surtout quand on a fait une pré la
présomption d'innocence dans le pays
quand on a des journalistes qui en fait
n'ont pas émis le moindre moi il ya
quelques rédactions comme médiapart
comme comme l'humanité de stars actions
qui ont qui ont signé un communiqué de
soutien gg en remercie mais voilà les
journalistes des chaînes d'information
mon lit mi-temps foncé avait déjà des
bandeaux à la limite limite ta boîte en
prison comme si j'étais déjà condamné
écoutez moi je n'avais souffert ou pote
ben écoutez moi je trouve ça désolant et
pessah et sans raconte plus sur eux que
sur moi et maintenant que je suis libéré
et que je suis entre guillemets blanchi
puisque pour le moment il n'y a rien qui
est retenu contre moi on veut m'inviter
pour faire leurs audiences banon et est
ce qui est assez drôle c'est que vous
savez j'ai un mail ici sur mon téléphone
vous savez ce qu'ils disent que je suis
pas journaliste pendant que le matin moi
c'est moi j'étais le seul journaliste
présent à la cfdt à l'envahissement la
cdt j'ai filmé j'aurais vendu des images
pendant qu'ils disaient ça il passé mes
images derrière c'était aboaf et pendant
que j'étais en garde à vue le matin j'ai
reçu un mail de la production de bfm tv
qui me dit monsieur boissons à utiliser
vos images du théâtre de macron on vous
rémunère comme d'habitude une aide de 3
une une pige de 300 euros net et pendant
salle alors présentateur disais que
c'était pas journaliste alors il ya ya
alexandre reynal
regarde merci à lui voilà qui si rien à
taiwan ne veut pas que je troll sur lui
mais quand il propose de jeter ses
chaussures sur le président twitter
devient un lieu d'humour et de blagues
voire même de provocation double
discours je te balance tout poste merci
alexandre bénin en tout cas ceux de
poissons de ce qui nous regarde en
direct actuellement voilà tout le monde
et devant balances ton post don qui vous
a répondu en direct ap